ouais
mais
edgar hébert selon vous à quoi est due
la vogue du short
bah moi avoue bien entendu je pense que
vous le saviez moi non il se trouve
simplement qu'à la dernière rentrée
j'avais un ami il tenait une boîte de
nuit à paris qui voulait relancer sa
boîte qui me posait la question de
savoir comment on pouvait faire une
relance de boîte de nuit à paris et puis
on a cherché on a découvert que au fond
les femmes étaient présentes bt très
empêtrés dans leurs grandes actimax y
est je dis bah c'est pas compliqué en a
perdu hélas la mini jupe
il faut les obliger à se mettre en
mini-short alors tu lances la soirée
mini short qui on verra bien ce que ça
donne
et puis par extraordinaire cinq ou six
jours après son arrivée à 50 qui avaient
coupé leurs pantalons pour ce faire des
mini shorts
oui comme les parisiennes une marche
comme ça on doit y aller c'était
merveilleux
le mini short ce n'est jamais que
la minijupe camoufler ya eu un accident
de parcours qui était le maxi et ça
alors là c'est un c'est un fait le même
travail sociologique que je ne maîtrise
pas encore mais il est évident que les
femmes ont besoin ou envie désire
aujourd'hui ce se mettre à nu soul et
alors c'est très symbolique ce qu'elles
font bas c'est un besoin de libération
énorme surtout sur tous les plans
moi j'aime bien
très bien
moi je parle
c'était son fric quand
sports6 tour mais j'aime pas celui ci
lance avec des gros dit john hyams jeu
les couplets est ce que ce sont les
femmes qui en fait la victoire du short
ou bien des fabricants d'une femme avant
tout et les fabricants ont suivi
facilement les fabricants ont eu
beaucoup de mal à suivre ils ont été
pris de court tout le monde avait prévu
du long pour cet été ce printemps ce qui
était une erreur d'ailleurs
du
omar sharif que pensez-vous du short de
la mode du short mais moi je trouve ça
fantastique personnellement je trouve
surtout que c'est c'est ce qu'une fille
m de mieux et je pense que n'importe qui
qui aime beaucoup les femmes aiment bien
les voir en show à moins qu'elle soit
très vilaine je trouve
on dit que par exemple il faut avoir de
très belles jambes pour porter le choc
mais je ne trouve pas tellement il faut
ne pas avoir des jambes affreuse mais je
trouve que très souvent le short les
jambes roues font au fond un plus bel
effet je veux dire même si elles sont
pas parfaites
si on vous dit que la mode du short se
situe dans un large mouvement de
libération de la femme
qu'est ce que vous répondez non moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression que c'est le
contraire moi je trouve que de short
puis l'absence soutien-gorge et tout ça
sonne exprime pas pour moi du tout la
libération de la femme sas exprime
plutôt le contraire
oui puisque ça exprime une certaine
féminité un désir de plaire à l'homme
donc une certaine servilité au contraire
en tant qu'avocat que pensez-vous du
château mais vous avez eu raison
d'interroger nomme de loi sur cette très
sérieuse question parce que le short
peut poser des problèmes sur le terrain
juridique
une femme portant choc pourrait être
reconnu responsable d'un accident de la
circulation la circulation de la route
et peut être aussi circulation sanguine
on ne sait jamais le short est fait pour
porter sur les stades pour porter au
grand jour et où le voit-on voit la nuit
et dans les boîtes
il est fait pour l'accomplissement des
sport viril même s'ils sont accomplis
par les femmes et à quoi sert-il à gérer
plus aisément alors une donne un peu
l'impression si vous voulez d'un d'un
chien de chasse dans un salon mal adapté
le chant d'abord c'est le printemps
donc il fait bon le long en avait marre
avoir les jambes quand on est dans la
voiture je prenais la tente
et puis donc ses cours on est aéré mais
c'est beaucoup plus décentes la minijupe
même pour la petite fille pour lui elles
sont ravies de se traîner juste collant
à laver vie ses tubes qui vous plus
pratique pour contre le short contre le
short
- tous les deux très jolies cuisses et
longue chemise venant porter par non
mais votre bureau je pense que ça fait
mauvais mais c'est d'ailleurs notre
patron de la diversité la question
un changement mais aussi un choc donc
cet amusant oui celui d'homme et la
génération seront une quarantaine
d'années tel est très danger springs est
venu en bretagne cet hiver
mais il veut pas dire non cette short
bermuda enfin short un peu indécent
du
je crois que c'est ridicule comme
d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir la réflexion
des gens qu'est ce qu'ils disent les
gens du célé il a des poils
après moi je suis content parce que ça
fait prendre un peu d'oxygène
il
ayala les boutiques